hey guys Jeff here from wacky gamer I
wanted to bring you the top 7 things
I've seen in the latest World of
Warcraft Cataclysm footage they finally
filled in Thunder Ridge outside of
Orgrimmar I don't know what Blizzard was
thinking but it's like let's put an area
in the new zone where you could fall to
your death and get your ass kicked by
thunder Coto trying to get out
yay no wrong no longer they added flight
points to stranglethorn Vale no more
running up and down just to empty your
bags for the Alliance because it made
the Alliance feel like the redheaded
stepchild of the factions the goblin
barge and Thousand Needles looks awesome
you know it's everything you would
expect it to be gritty there's gears
everywhere sort of looks like it was
built out of the spare parts from the
customer car my dad never finished
building man he really loved that 94
Fiat Punto no idea why
Westphal really needed something to
break up all that big boring yellow
nothingness it has the giant crater is a
nice addition that maelstrom in the
middle don't know exactly what it is is
it like a giant hurricane a magical
vortex result of a dragon fart who knows
but all I do know is really awesome and
you shouldn't cast any fire lightning
spells nearby I don't know if you've
seen a dragon fart explode but it ain't
pretty
they made Orgrimmar grittier which is
awesome with all the construction
equipment in the dark coloring scheme
one major complaint people had was it
wasn't hardcore enough they really
needed the city to be an icon that could
justify the Mealing fall to hold online
for Toy Story Mania at Disneyland during
Blizzcon know for the Alliance
was though Abba Lyons in the house you
there is grass and desolace now big big
news a lot of people you're sitting
going who cares I do is hopefully now
when I level a character through there
the coda won't shake my damn camera like
it always used to and finally the worgen
male dance there's one thing World of
Warcraft needed it was Justin Timberlake
and now I can get my Timberlake on
actually I gotta go I'm gonna go
watching Dance Central videos
you